hey guys little project today is uh i
gotta get this uh plow set up because i
gotta go plow the barbecue parking lot
out anyway i bought one of those weld on
plates for a quick hitch
and i welded it onto a plow blade i had
bought at an auction
and this is it right here there's the
work master and here's the plow i set up
it's welded there welded down there i
use a piece of box steel so i got to put
the angle cylinders on that's my next
thing
all right we're getting parts
all right i got pins i hope these pins
work all right so i got the thing hooked
up
now i'm going to try to do a little
plowing
i finally got it pinned in i had to go
bang into that snow bank over there to
get it so the pins would work
so let's go do a little plowing i think
i got angle now
look at that
oh
it went all the way that way now it's
not going back
oh i gotta switch to the other handle in
case i want to put like a rotary mower
on
it has to dump all the way back to the
sump on the tractor
know why that thing won't go in there
all right guys i got pressure on it
well best way to do that is to turn the
tractor off
turn the tractor off
cycle this
hopefully i'll drop the pressure
down and i can get this to plug in
yep there we go that works every time
boy i got my hands oiled up that new
holland hydraulic oil is good for my
complexion
okay back out see what happens
i went one way and it didn't go to the
other
well that don't make any sense
maybe it's not what i thought it was
[Music]
because it's stuck
always some
go bang into a snow pile
now let's see what it does
seems like out of work
well let's go plowing
so
oh that works
wow
i wonder why it doesn't float more
actually works pretty good
all right i'm gonna go over plow the
parking lot see how that works
oh know i gotta get used to this thing
i don't know why float doesn't work so
well
i'm gonna keep dumping i gotta keep
picking the bucket up
wow
that was the best push so far
this stuff's gonna freeze up sell as a
rock
oh the winds are blowing
i might want to put gloves on ah
yeah the wind though it's gotta be 30
mile an hour winds that's awesome
[Music]
do
oh gotta get my battery charging
[Music]
well let's get back on the tractor and
see what's going on
i hope this mic's working
i don't know if it is or not
i think i kind of like this thing it
seems to be working okay
once i get the angle i got to set the
angle of the uh
the bucket tilt
the tilt's got to be right or it doesn't
doesn't seem to want to work good
also it works better with the blade
straighter it doesn't dig in as much so
that's kind of good to know
weather's a little icky out today
all right let's see if we can get this
plowed out nice
[Music]
wow i like having this on a boom i could
i could pick it up and just shove stuff
way back
that again give that another sweep
i think we're gonna get more snowing i'm
gonna have to plow again
before we open on thursday
we'll see what happens
ah scraped up a little grass
nothing too bad
be really nice if the sun came out
melted this stuff
almost kept hitting the wrong lever
all right we're gonna get close to the
building
what i like about this work master i got
the uh forward reverse shuttle
and a regular standard shift
everybody wants hydrostatic hydrostatic
sucks down more power
and honestly this reverse shuttle is
the shift on the fly back and forth
you can almost if you're not going too
fast you can shift it without clutching
i don't know how they work it but it
works
all righty where am i going now
yeah i gotta finish this out
[Music]
oh
do
[Applause]
[Music]
all right i think i got her good enough
anyway
yeah the only weird thing is depending
on where the angle is
i gotta i gotta roll the bucket back or
forth
got to be careful getting in the barn i
don't want to crash into anything
tight squeeze
all right
and we're back let's see if our welds
held up i think they did
ah
nothing seems broke but i don't have to
do something with these hoses this one's
ripping way down there
ah i don't know
get it like this i'm probably just gonna
oh you guys trying to attach them there
or something i don't know
but looks like i got them plenty long
enough
all right well
that looks like about a wrap for right
now
so just a little video doing some
plowing uh if you like my videos like
and subscribe and share that'll be great
trying to build up a little channel here
so uh
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
and that's always good for the algorithm
it's so mysterious an algorithmic